il était un peu déboussolé ce matin
après six mois de cours à la maison
les étudiants de la faculté de droit ont
retrouvé les bancs des amphis oui ça
fait depuis mars n'est pas aller en
cours et leur revenir en en chine avec
une place sur deux même les amphis moins
bondée ça oui ça fait bizarre même avec
les ya eu on a eu du coup une nouvelle
un nouveau truc imposé par la fac avec
du coup on est en semaine à semaine b
les amphis sont divisés par deux mais
c'est spécial mais il ya toujours quand
même cette petite pointe d'appréhension
de se dire qu'on est énormément dans
cette fac et que forcément il y aura des
quatre coronavirus mais globalement
sinon ça va en tout le monde à le
masquer
il ya tout le temps du gel à disposition
c'était la rentrée aussi pour cette
professeur de droit devant elle deux
cents étudiants au lieu de 400 pour
respecter les distanciation social c'est
une nouvelle organisation à mettre en
place et nous les enseignants nous
allons faire ce qu'on appelle des
enseignements hybride c'est-à-dire qui
aura une partie de cours dans lequel
nous accueillerons un petit groupe en
présentiel et puis une partie de cours à
distance et le système est conçu pour
que y ait une forme de rotation
son cours est désormais filmer pour
permettre aux autres étudiants de suivre
à distance s'est équipée et ont ces
derniers mois on a équipé ont été assez
peu équipée de quais numérique soit 2
moyen de captation vidéo ou d'outils de
webconférence déjà c'est le premier
point est le deuxième point si
l'attention particulière sur les ce
qu'on appelle les étudiants
primo-entrants ce dîner au match est
liée pour faire en sorte de les
accueillir eux de les prioriser pour les
accueillir en présence hier à la
bibliothèque universitaire impossible
d'accueillir tous les étudiants
d'habitude la bibliothèque compte 1100
places assises dorénavant seulement 500
seront proposés et les étudiants devront
les réserver ils sont aussi obligés de
réserver via une application influence à
l'avance comme ça ça nous permet aussi
éventuellement un traçage de savoir qui
est rentré dans la bibliothèque fini
aussi les travaux en groupe
les salles sont désormais individuelles
et les 10000 livres empruntés à
l'extérieur seront à leur tour mises en
quarantaine pendant trois jours